man i remember one christmas i don't
know how old i was
so i was in sunday school mm-hmm and i
[ __ ] hated sunday school because
why the [ __ ] would i want to go to like
i i to as well when you're like eight
i didn't understand why i cared about
why i should care about
jesus and [ __ ] right to me i was like
who is this guy and why do i care
right yeah or or who is this guy who's
man
who's the big j man that everyone keeps
talking about man and so
i remember this i [ __ ] hated it my
parents for some reason
because my parents right they i not to
out my parents here right but
they they wanted they said they were
religious my parents are [ __ ]
they just wanted to be real yeah it's
literally like i feel like the white
suburban family it's like we're
yeah we believe in jesus yeah we love
j-man yeah we love him man we're all
you know my you know whatever and i'm
like we're not [ __ ] released you're
just like well you know i actually yes
my mom and dad was last time when they
went to church and it's like
how many decades 1972 right so they put
me they had the genius idea to put all
of
me and my brothers in sunday school and
my older brother he never complains
about stuff he just gets on with it
right right and
me you know me i like to complain okay
before before we get into your story
okay what is sunday school oh do you
don't know okay true
it's like a church school right so yeah
it's like i mean it's in america as well
i think it's more popular in america but
in the
uk as well it's normally for like
christian stuff or catholic or whatever
what'd you learn in sunday school i've
because i've never been to school jesus
i i just know
about sunday school so i think i was too
young to do like the super religious
stuff
so ninety percent of the time they just
spoke about like religious they would
tell stories and i remember being like
who the [ __ ] cares
and also i remember coloring in so many
pictures
so many [ __ ] pictures and i remember
when did you have like a jesus coloring
book yeah we had like a jesus coloring
page and i [ __ ] hated it because i
was like
i was like who is this guy why do i care
why am i coloring this guy
this is the fifth time we've colored in
his birth do we really need to keep
coloring
i do and also one time and it was
you know i'd watch tv shows you know
american cartoons and they had like the
paddling balls
very very vivid memory yeah one time one
of the kids bringing in the paddling
balls and it was like the coolest
[ __ ] thing yeah yeah
and they immediately took it away from
him and i was like no i want to play
with the pedaling ball
why did i take away from him i don't
know because it's jesus time
no one interrupts jesus and they made us
do like a play at christmas when i was
like eight or nine
oh well like the birth of jesus yeah
yeah i think
and i remember being like mom you're one
of the wise men yeah i was one of the
wiser
oh man you got you got a you got a big
role i was the snowman
but i think it was because that was
literally what i did
i i i literally just did this on stage
my mom still has pictures being like
great performance
great performance i think i was one of
the wise men only because
i there wasn't enough kids to fill the
other world
because there wasn't enough kids in this
school i hated it i remember and then
also i was like why do i have to have my
mom
he's got gold i want gold that's
[ __ ] and i didn't know how to say
murr at the time when i was a kid
gold i know gold mother come on give me
it
and i remember we had to do this shitty
play and i was like i hate this so much
i hate it
and so for one christmas i asked my mom
i was like she was like what do you want
for christmas
i did i slipped her in the eyes and i
was like i don't care about gifts just
please don't make me go to sunday school
i i want my sundays back mom i'm going
to school five days a week
and then another day after turn up and
[ __ ] color pictures of jesus
are you kidding me i hate this [ __ ] and
i think honestly that's the reason why i
just care for like zero religion now
right because they pushed it so heavily
on me and i'm like this is [ __ ] it's all
a bunch of nonsense yeah yeah yeah we're
reading book stories about this dude who
i don't give a [ __ ] about like there's
no concept
so you went to you went to a catholic
school as well no it wasn't it wasn't a
catholic school but they did make us
pray
three times a day wait so what so in
wales like a lot of schools should make
you pray
oh because it's like a religious culture
even if it's like an atheist like school
there's no atheist school it's just like
it's a school and a lot of them have
like it's just a school yeah in my
uh secondary school and my primary
school i think you pray three times a
day
oh wow but the thing is right that you
realize
maybe like in high school you're like oh
they can't they won't they don't tell
you off
if you don't pray because they can't
right because it's a religious thing but
it's a school
it's still like a school rule well no
it's like a school suggestion
it's like a cult right because when you
get in this thing right you go to school
and then everyone suddenly bows their
head and starts [ __ ]
speaking in tongues right you're like oh
[ __ ] okay i should probably join in on
this i don't want to be the only one
left out
but then you realize after all oh
they're not going to do anything if i
don't pray and just stand there and look
around and be like what's going on you
see
all the other kids and so i would i
would just refuse to do it eventually
because i'm like i'm not praying
this nonsense all right i don't
understand why they made us do it i
because we want to religiously that's
the thing it's like i i find that a bit
weird because it would make sense if you
went to like a christian school or
catholic school it might have been like
i it wasn't officially a christian
school but i think a lot of the schools
in wales were like
christian or something i i think just a
lot of schools in england are like that
yeah anyway because uh i like i don't
think i went to a catholic or religious
but we still had to like we still did
religious things around christmas time
and i know i had no idea what the [ __ ]
was going on yeah [ __ ] because like i i
come from a buddhist family
so like we'd have events in the church
and stuff like this
i'm like whatever this is this isn't the
temple what is this
god we've just like sing like welsh
hymns and they're the [ __ ] worst
things
i had to sing hymns as well had no idea
what they were what they were no
there was one and like it was called
like dorth alvin
and it means come on my head
so jamie please
hate yourself i know it's your birthday
and all the [ __ ] hell it's literally
called like daughter
right yeah which literally translates on
my head so every time they would like
because
there was a sheet of 12 hymns and they
would never do drawn out for men
because everyone would always like look
at each other and giggle and
because like the chorus was just
shouting like like loudly
like they would never pick it because
everyone would just start screaming [ __ ]
on my head
in welsh because they found it because
they're all [ __ ] kids
and every time they pick it it was like
a [ __ ] event because every all the
kid
it was the one time where all the kids
who didn't really sing and go in and
would start would proudly say i feel
like
my boys in queue right
yeah that's weird because like i went to
my high school was like a catholic
school
even though i'm not catholic personally
but like we didn't even have to do like
the whole like praying thing like we
would have to do you know maybe like a
like a like an end of end of term mass
or like a beginning of term masses yeah
that's like bring on the new year but
yeah we never had to do anything
i i did it was one of those things that
when you left you're like that was weird
wasn't it that was that was weird that
they made us pray
we would like pray before every meal and
stuff like that yeah that's a bit weird
yeah it is weird what's up with that
whales man come on